[Music]
if this is any only Tamagotchis I had
like three and they died within a day
Robo babies she's not even a cyborg
there's no human to love Eugene and I
are both very competitive so that means
our baby is going to be the best I can't
take care of myself as long as don't
have to make an emotional commitment to
anything I should be good
[Applause]
so today we got robot babies we're
having a baby this is exactly how I
pictured it would happen it's basically
a robot baby it's used in like schools
it's used in health classes to teach
like baby curriculum and you have to
change its diapers you have to feed it
you have to burp it you have to rock it
you have to change its diaper you change
a robot's diaper so this is like birth
right now this is birth these baby get
out it's not alive yet right I'm allowed
to mishandle it now my turn
more like haven't you always I thought
every white person wants an Asian baby
right he has blue eyes he gets those
from me
he's also tiny sort of like you yeah
look how much hair he has just like his
father
I can hear something rocking in it
that's probably its sensor of I'm being
abused we have to name the baby yeah I
think it's important for a name to have
something of significance I'm thinking
Maurice Maurice corns burger I was
another baby bring our baby to life and
three two does it move doesn't seem like
it that oh it's the yes hi Maurice
welcome hi JJ hi JJ what you want what
does he want
how do you know they just crying hey
buddy just dab it at its face just pull
the dude and I know in how I don't know
when I fed him too much he'll let you
know do we have to burp him is that what
we're doing how do we know he needs to
burp right now he's just going this
seems excessive you're prepping it for a
long time you poor babies for a long
time let me try I swear I'm gonna bury
this sound like a fart
diaper change that felt like a poopy I
know I know
[Music]
put the diaper run exact no he doesn't
want it I was sorry I was laughing at
his penis so Clampett his penis the
penis is hilarious I cannot laugh at it
stop trying please
how was it you just knows it is he dead
did you kill it he's not dead right wait
we didn't so tonight we're gonna take
our babies home it's gonna record our
results at the end of the night the
baby's going to generate a report and
we're gonna stay up all night trying to
take care of the baby well ya know we're
gonna try and get a good night's sleep
not one that's gonna happen I just this
moment had a realization of how hellish
the next 24 hours are gonna be what
happened last night we should start at
the beginning start at the beginning we
left the office very excited full of
energy I thought you know Keith and I
having a sleepover that's gonna be a fun
time he's a cutie pie I realize he's
cute and we're in charge of him Ned's
wife came for a visit at the beginning
of the night that was so nice but have
some like family hell's dude so once we
have the baby down to sleep it was
delightful some work yeah we're raising
this baby both religions we listen to
classical music but I do want Maurice to
have one we drank a nice Riesling but
you can't do anything to his dick what
are you talking about and it was really
Pleasant we I already checked it he's
not circumcised yet of course not so we
get set to go to sleep and you maybe you
strip Maurice and then I'll trust him
back up again baby's adorable
our baby looks amazing we put our baby
in the separate room so it had its own
like nursery you know we figured out how
to make a bed we now go to him up in his
blank a say good night good night keep
those eggs
goodnight Zack thank you I think I think
he might be good the whole night you're
crazy
[Music]
so in 130 mm oh no - is it - he
activated and he just flipped I change
its diaper nothing perfect nothing
bottle nothing sometimes I was like what
do you want what do you want I don't
know what you need baby screaming
screams by the third time it was more of
a can you do it it's just a demon and
it's just bad she's screaming at as me
do one of us do coke during your
pregnancy
I have to say the baby was the source of
the stress but the source of my anger
was this was a crib you can't sleep if
this was a crib you can't sleep in the
baby
it's a nightmare I just hold my child
and we're just up forever it seems like
with this baby we just can't go back to
bed by the time the Sun came out we were
just over it
[Music]
I gotta take a shower so his act is
gonna watch the baby that's what babies
are sometimes I think how awful this
thing was was incredibly accurate you
really have to have teamwork and
patience with each other I feel like it
brought us closer it was less stressful
with him than I can imagine without him
it's it's a lot a lot of work
Oh Oh what is that a see put the see see
what I'm unsatisfied with that to be
honest no miss Ana we didn't come it's
neck I was sure
[Music]
we're great parents I don't you know
what all this now I'm like I don't even
care how tired I am I'm like so elated
that we did a great job this is from the
two guys who just said they hated their
baby five seconds ago yes I did hate it
five seconds ago now that I'm a winner
I'm thrilled seeing your baby laughs for
the first time would be just it would
make everything that you did all the
late nights just so much so worth it